Hi, I'm Tiffany Young and this is everything I do in a day.
My usual schedule is waking up around 10 a.m.
When I actually get out of bed, the first thing I do is search for caffeine,...
...and then hop into the shower,...
...and then I head out.
I have a notebook for rehearsal and I write down all the things we rehearse each day.
Everything is at rehearsal at this point.
I'm in downtown L.A.
It starts usually at 12 p.m.
We start from warming up, we'll be harmonizing for hours,...
...going over the set list and the transition,...
...and then we go song by song,...
...and then we'll record it and I'll step back and I'll want to listen...
...and see what we need to work on and yeah, lock in.
Typical lunch, 30 to 40 minute break.
I usually unwind at the rehearsal studio.
8 p.m., meet friends for dinner.
10 p.m., I need to hit the gym.
At this point, I'm ready to kind of relax and unwind and go home.